here where never has heard a
discouraging word
is nothing but joy and desire
it's from Orpheus and eurydice
the Opera by glock is playing at the
Manhattan opera house oh I'm sorry you
listen to Opera now you don't know my
life
enlight me please
travels to Hades to get back his dead
wife and he's given permission to return
to Earth with her under the condition
that he not look at her face until
they're out of Hades why I don't know
because the gods are dicks anyway or if
you can't resist but look at eurydice's
face because people are weak and love
makes fools out of everyone
so he ends up losing her all over him
I'm gonna go see it
why obviously
it has meaning for her
oh okay okay uh how do you know if she's
even going if she does you still won't
know when
I'll just keep going until she shows up
oh you'll just keep going
that is that is so crazy
yeah
yeah but like she said
love makes fools of everyone
[Music]
foreign
I'm not sure
I'm sorry well I mean everyone starts
with strangers
I don't know a lot of people
and we both like comfortable Footwear
Jordan Ones I see I'm more of an 11s
kind of girl
that's cool I I have them those
sneakers I have sneakers at home nice
and in my mind because I didn't go with
the stress you know no
so
did you um did you like the show
very much so actually
oh it was so
hopeful
really yeah
sure there's a lot of pain and suffering
but I ultimately love wins in the end
there's no joy without the struggle they
go hand in hand
just have faith keep looking forward
at least that's what I saw
so strange
I've seen the show so many times I never
saw it like that
it's about how you hear the music
would you like my number
if you want to talk more about the show
or other Jordans
I'm Rob real Prince
they're all brands a mirror
oh that's my personal number oh how many
other numbers do you have no just one
for work
of course
I guess
we're not strangers anymore
I guess not
so sorry
[Music]
foreign
we talked
last night at the Opera well there we go
okay
and it's true and get get this she
thinks
I am interesting oh really how do we
know this information oh she texted her
dead boyfriend about me I found his
Facebook profile what
yeah he's who she's been texting this
whole time I must have the dead
boyfriend's number yeah
yeah oh my God he's her she's she's
calling me right now
we'll leave a message what do I do what
do I do Rob answer the phone answer this
is unbearable
yo
um hi hi this is Mira Ray from the Opera
last night oh yeah hey hey yeah
how the heck are you
I'm good
um how are you I hope this isn't a bad
time no no no no no no no I'm just at
work you know but you know you're not
interrupting anything which I I work to
live you know and I'll live to work
at the chronicle
cool
I mean I love a Chris Winter's day in
New York City
the weather
hey I was wondering do you eat
just ask me if I eat
I mean I I know you eat at least I
assume you do you know but some people
they're just not into food they they do
it because they have to also they would
die
but I I love food I Can't Get Enough
unless I call some fool and then I'm
like no I'm all set here
yeah so specifically I was wondering
would you like to eat with me
tonight
uh yeah I mean I love food too
do you like cheeseburgers
are you kidding
she's perfect
I love cheeseburgers
um I know this cute little spot called
Roxy's um
do you want to meet there say like seven
tonight yeah
perfect that's seven that's my favorite
time to meet
okay well I'll let him see it we'll see
ya
wow I have no words
oh my God congratulations you just got
yourself a date the normal way no apps